[MUSIC PLAYING]
MATTHEW SOLDO: Three things.
First of all, I made this up.
The 11 factors of productive
software organization.
That is an intentional take on
the Twelve-Factor App, which
maybe some of you have heard of.
That was a guideline
for how to design apps
in a PaaS or
serverless environment
that Adam Wiggins
from Heroku did.
I am an alumni of Heroku
so I feel like it's
OK to kind of riff on that.
Originally, I thought I had 12
factors, but off by one errors.
They happen.
So little funny story.
Adam basically made up
those 12 factors the night
before Heroku's first
developer conference.
They were based on a
lot of great experience,
but he basically just
threw together a website--
the Twelve-Factor website.
Put them together.
I basically did the same thing.
When I was flying in yesterday
I collected my thoughts on what
works and what doesn't as
[INAUDIBLE] and it turns out
I had about the right number.
And so now we've got the
11 factors of productivity.
We'll talk a little about
why serverless in general.
And spoiler alert,
using serverless
is the last factor
of being productive,
so that's how we tie
the two together.
And we'll also talk about
what's new in App Engine.
So why should you listen to me?
Did I just make
all this stuff up?
Yes, I did.
These are some of
the other places
I've worked over my career.
The first two were not in
cloud, but it was actually--
PayPal and Amazon was a
super interesting dichotomy.
I did an internship at
PayPal, and PayPal was still
in the monolith software
app mode when I was there.
Things were really,
really slow to develop.
It was very, very painful
to get things done.
It made being a product
manager not very fun.
It made me think I wanted to
be a product marketing manager,
and then I actually tried that
and that wasn't fun either.
Turns out it just wasn't
the right place to do it.
Then I got to Amazon.
I was actually working in the
advertising team at Amazon.
But Amazon, in a lot of widely
publicized papers and talks,
had a few years earlier gone
through this transformation,
where they took
this one big [? C ?]
app that was all of Amazon--
I mean, this was circa
2003 or 2004 or 2005.
And they split it into
hundreds of services.
I think that was
even before services
were called microservices.
And I got to experience
that firsthand.
I saw that actually
it really did work
and it really was beneficial.
But I wanted to find the
Silicon Valley startup story,
and it just so happened that
I had a failed startup where
I built a Ruby on Rails
app and taught myself Ruby.
And I was looking for a role
and literally on the Crunchbase
want ads saw a job for a PM
at this company called Heroku.
And I tried it out when
I was doing that app.
And I was one of the
first dozen people there.
I PM'd Heroku Postgres and
the main Heroku product.
And I got to see both
internally Heroku--
the things we did well on
being really productive
as an organization
and the things
we did really, really not well.
And I also got to see lots and
lots of customer apps running
on Heroku and see those
same good and bad.
After that, I was at Docker
for a couple of years.
Again, sort of got to see both
internally some good practices
and bad practices, and also
lots of customer good practices
and bad practices.
And then I found
Google Cloud and I've
been enjoying that ever since.
All right.
So let's talk about
the 11 or 12 factors
of a productive software team.
Number one, the
[INAUDIBLE] motto.
Build something people want.
It doesn't matter how
productive you are.
You can make things
lightning fast.
If you build things that are
useless, that nobody wants,
that don't have product market
fit, that is the biggest
productivity suck.
Essentially, your
productivity is zero
if you build things that
nobody actually uses.
How do you do that?
Well, it's actually
not too hard.
Talk to customers
before you build things.
There's a ton of documentation
on this on the web.
Talk to people.
Emailing people doesn't count.
You might email folks.
It's not the same medium.
It is amazingly low bandwidth
versus actually talking
to people.
I actually like to think of it--
if you've ever seen
"Gorillas in the Mist."
Jane Goodall, she
was in the jungle
observing the chimpanzees.
And that's what you want to do
to figure out what you want.
Whether you're an enterprise
company or a consumer company,
go to your target
audience's native habitat.
Watch what they do.
See the problems they encounter.
Don't ask them about solutions.
If you understand the
problems really well,
then you can make good
solutions for them.
And to me, that is the
key to making things
that people actually want.
So this is actually something
that one of my colleagues
at Amazon said.
I thought it was the
funniest thing ever.
I added the parentheses here.
Premature optimization
is the root of all evil.
This happens again and again
and again in software orgs.
You'll say, well, we
can't do it this way
because that won't scale.
Well, who cares?
Do the fast thing
that doesn't scale.
This way you can test out
if what you're building
is actually useful for people.
Don't solve problems that you
don't have yet because that
means-- if you don't have the
problem yet that means you
don't understand the problem.
You might think you're solving
a scaling problem you're
going to hit in six
months, but odds
are in six months the actual
scaling problems you'll hit
will be completely different.
Or if you are right, you'll
understand it even better.
And sort of corollary to
that, don't plan for scaling
more than 10x past
where you are,
even if you're in
hyper growth mode.
If you're growing double
digit percentages every month
in terms of the usage
of your product--
presumably software
product-- you
might want to plan for
three months down the line
when you're 50% bigger.
But don't plan for when
you're 10x bigger because it's
really hard to imagine that.
Just keep doing those three
month, six month things.
Another great way to avoid
premature optimization
that I've seen work in
various forms is sneaker wear.
You might have some
really, really hard problem
and it's going to take a
ton of time to solve it.
But if you can solve
it by just faking it
that works really well.
A story there that
illustrates that.
When I first got to Heroku,
we had this dedicated database
product.
There was a shared
database product
where you got one
database on a big cluster
and we could spin those
up programmatically
in a couple of seconds, and
that's what most people used.
But if you wanted to pay the
massive amount of $200 a month
you could get this
dedicated database.
You had a whole virtual
machine to yourself.
So it turns out if you went into
the interface, you clicked it,
you'd get a message that
says your database will be
available in 24 hours or less.
What really happened was it
emailed one of the engineers
at Heroku.
They went into the AWS console,
they spun up a virtual machine,
then they went in and manually
configured your app to use it.
That worked great
for the first year
there when we had
about a couple hundred
of those dedicated databases.
Pretty soon, we were seeing
that it wasn't scaling.
That's when we fixed it.
But if we had said, no,
no, no, we need to scale.
We need to plan for the
future, the whole product
would've been out
12 months later,
and we wouldn't have learned
a whole lot of other things
that we learned.
So don't prematurely optimize.
This is basically the opposite.
How do you avoid
premature optimization?
It's so hard to do.
Even if you're just
writing some code
you might be adding
some extra tables
to your database or
some extra fields.
You'll be like, well,
I don't need this now
but I'm going to need it later,
and it doesn't cost anything.
Still costs mental
bandwidth, still takes time,
still has the opportunity
to create bugs.
So a really great way to
avoid premature optimization
is something called a spike.
That's where you
build something.
You give yourself some
really short amount of time--
one week or two weeks--
and you tell
yourself or your team
we are not going to
use any of the code
that we write this week.
We are purely doing this
just to test to make sure
that we can build some
software that actually works,
that bears some
resemblance to the app
we ultimately want to make.
What's great is after
you make a spike,
you can try it out with
customers, get their feedback.
You also may encounter some of
the hard technical challenges
in actually building the thing.
You might try to do something.
Make a dedicated database
and you realize, oh, man.
That's really,
really, really hard.
And so it's a method of
discovering what's hard
and what's not
and testing to see
if the thing you're going
to build is actually useful.
Often, I've seen teams plan
to do two or three spikes,
basically a week or two each,
and then go on and build
the actual thing.
Sometimes you'll discover
that your spike is actually
totally good enough to
be the actual product,
and isn't that awesome?
You've got something
in two weeks
that you can then
actually start deploying.
Another thing.
I found that really proactive
organizations are generally
shipping really
good quality things.
It feels great to
ship something good,
it feels really bad
to ship something bad,
and it's really,
really hard to do.
I think we sort of have this
prototype in software of Steve
Jobs, who's the quality tyrant.
He was famous for
berating people,
when the quality wasn't
up to his standards,
about how bad a job
they were doing.
So I think the trick
here is you want
to be ruthless about
quality but you never
attack the person for something
that's not high quality.
You talk about the
product that was created.
You assume good intentions and
you don't make it personal,
but you still have a really,
really high quality bar.
And I think ultimately,
everybody will feel really,
really good about
building good things,
and that actually
really helps quite a bit
for having a productive org.
All right, next.
Start with the monolith.
Microservices is all
the rage these days.
You read a ton about it.
You'll read blog posts about
my microservices architecture
for building the next dog
food selling e-commerce site.
Actually, at one of the
places I was at the team
was building some web services--
not going to name names--
and they were living in
the microservices world
so they decided to make it a
microservices app from day one.
It had five or six
different services.
It was a total mess.
This is really just a corollary
to the premature optimization.
What happened in that
case was the team
was solving problems that
they didn't understand.
They thought the
microservices architecture
would solve things really well.
It actually made
everything harder.
So it's really simple.
Start off with a
single code base,
and then as you discover
what's wrong you split it off,
and I think that's
actually the next slide.
So if you do start
with a monolith,
does that mean you stay
a monolith forever?
No.
That's what PayPal
did and eBay did.
That's what slowed them down
and let Amazon overtake them
15 years ago.
It's almost hard to remember
but back then Amazon and PayPal
were like neck and neck,
or Amazon and eBay.
So you don't stay
a monolith forever.
You split out services as you
discover your scaling problems,
and those scaling problems
can be organizational
or they can be technical.
For example, one pattern
I've seen over and over
and over again is some software
is getting some really, really
good uptake and it's starting to
hit some performance problems.
And when you look
at it, it might
be the database that is causing
the performance problems,
but it's like one table is
95% of all the databases load,
or 98%.
At Heroku we had a
group messaging app.
Basically, their whole
reason to [INAUDIBLE]
was that you couldn't send
group text messages on iPhones.
It's kind of crazy to remember.
So they had this group
messaging app to solve that.
It worked really, really well.
They started as a monolith.
They had a Postgres
database and there
was a messages
table that was 98%
of the load on their database.
And it pretty quickly
got to the point
where they couldn't scale
up a single database larger
than what they had.
They were using the very
biggest database out there.
There were a lot of other
data stores besides Postgres
that would have
been great for them
and that were great for them.
So what they did, they
split out of service.
It was a messaging
service that it
was backed by a database that
was ideal for that workload.
And boom, they solved the
problem and they moved on.
Another common scaling
thing is the team.
I'm a believer in
the two pizza rule.
If you can't feed your
team on two pizzas
then it might be time
to split it apart,
or can everybody fit in
the conference room thing.
Whatever the end law is of
the number of connections
in the team, it becomes
really, really hard
once you get past 12 or 15
people to be a cohesive team.
So maybe your scaling
problem is organizational.
You split out a separate
team, and then they
can act as their own team.
It works really well.
I'm going to skip
to number eight
here because that's
correlated to this.
So when you do split out
microservices and teams--
and this is really,
really important--
you need to make
them technically
and organizationally
independent.
What do I mean by that?
I mean there is actually a
team behind each service.
The whole notion
of a microservice
that kind of manages itself is,
I think, a bit of a fallacy.
It does happen, but the
pattern I've seen over and over
and over again is you
have a microservice.
It has its own team.
Really simple.
The teams can be as
little as one person,
although you hope they
don't get hit by a bus,
or they could be a
full two pizza team.
But this works
really, really well.
That way that team can
develop its own culture.
They can have their
own planning process.
Maybe they decide to do a two
week sprint instead of one week
sprint because that's what works
best for their own code base,
but they're their
own separate team.
From a technical
perspective, independence
means that the team can
deploy their own code
base independently.
And this is a really
easy smell if you've
done microservices wrong.
If to deploy your service
another team needs
to do a new deployment
of their service,
and so you need to do this
weird coordinated thing
between the two services,
you did it wrong.
You're not getting the
benefits of a microservice.
You just made it harder
to deploy new software.
So how do you do that?
You have stable versioned
APIs that the services
use to talk to each other.
Those APIs can be HTTP APIs.
They can be other APIs.
It doesn't matter.
They could just be
going on a UNIX socket,
but there's an API,
that thing stays stable,
then each of the
services can move as fast
as they want around that API.
Occasionally, you'll
have to break that.
Occasionally, you
realize that API
doesn't have the capabilities.
That's why you version it.
You create a new
version of the API.
The service that's
consuming that API is still
using the old version.
Once that new version
of the API is out there,
then it can switch over on
its own schedule to using
the new version of the API.
I skipped over number seven.
So again, this is a team thing.
I've found that
teams work best when
they're either all
co-located or all remote.
Co-location can be
a fabulous thing
if it works for your company.
You get the water
cooler conversations.
It's easy to drop
by somebody's desk
if you need some
question answered.
But for a lot of folks that's
not practical, in which case
you're in remote mode.
Everybody's remote.
That means every meeting
has a video conference
or a conference call
that they can be on.
That means you over
index on writing things
down so that if somebody
is in a different time zone
and there was a meeting
they missed they can just
read what happened.
And essentially, if you
have a hybrid team where
you have half the
people in one location
and half the people
remote, you basically just
need to act like
everybody's remote
and then it works pretty well.
But I think that's one of the
really interesting challenges
in terms of
productivity software.
How do you get remote teams
working better together?
And I'd love to see some cool
innovation there because right
now it's basically-- the
state-of-the-art that I've seen
is you have a shared Google Doc
on a meeting so anybody can see
that doc.
You have a video conference,
and it's pretty good.
Not quite the same as everybody
being in the same room,
but it's still pretty good.
OK, we already did this one.
What is this one?
Oh, yeah, so you started
off with a monolith.
You scaled, your product
is getting traction,
you started splitting into
separate microservices
with separate teams.
Now you've got a new problem.
This is a problem that
we totally had at Heroku
that we did wrong.
You'll have teams that might
be really, really productive
and they're all moving
in different directions.
It's like they're all running
in totally different ways,
and so that's not
really good either.
So you really have to over
index on your cohesive strategy.
There's a lot of
different ways to do this.
I'm a big believer,
if you can do it,
in having first principles--
Elon Musk is a big fan of
this first principle thing.
What does that mean?
I heard this really cool quote
from a friend of a friend.
He was talking to somebody
who worked at SpaceX,
and somebody said, what
do you do at SpaceX?
The way he answered
it is colonizing Mars
is essential to humanity's
future existence.
In order to do that,
we need to build
a spaceship powerful enough
and economical enough
to get us there.
And in order to do that,
we need to have engines
that have a thrust of this.
And so I work on the
exhaust valve of the engines
in order to make that happen.
So there's that first principle
of we need to colonize Mars,
and that lets that
engineer figure out
how to build that exhaust valve
to solve the problems that
actually matter.
Another way to do it is--
what you need when you have
a bunch of different teams
is essentially just some
central strategy czar.
Typically, I had a
product or a co-founder
or a CEO that just
continually says,
we're doing this, and making
sure people aligned to it.
I think when you
have separate teams
you want to have at least half
to 70% of their time working
on projects that are for
the whole organization.
But still give them
maybe like 20% time
to work on their own projects,
whether that's technical debt
reduction or just some
features that they think
would be important, because
they might have some ground
truth from their
interactions with the market
or their software
development that they
realize something is important.
It's not important
to the whole org
but it's important
to their part of it,
so give those separate
teams their 20% or 40%
time to work on separate,
independent projects as well.
Like they say in politics,
it's the economy, stupid.
I think in organizations
it's the culture.
It's sort of trite,
but it's really true.
You want to create a place
that people enjoy working at.
They enjoy hanging out
with their colleagues.
That will get you through a lot.
Confession.
I went to business
school, and you
do a lot of case studies
in business school.
And one of my meta takeaways,
when you read-- all the cases
are always about
successful companies.
And in almost every
successful company
in one of these case
studies, there's
always some really interesting,
unique factor in their culture.
It's kind of like another way
of having that strategy that
helps different teams figure
out what they need to do.
And last but not
least, use serverless.
This is a talk about
serverless so I
couldn't have left this out.
But it really is
true, and that's
what I'm going to
talk about next.
And by serverless I don't
mean just functions.
I mean platforms as a service,
app-based serverless things,
container-based serverless
things like Cloud Run
that we launched.
But serverless
really, really, really
can be a giant
productivity boost.
You are eliminating
so much of the stuff
that you would normally have
to do in running software.
It's not for everything,
but for a lot of software
it is really great.
And so that brings us
to the next section.
So why serverless
and why App Engine?
Obviously I'm doing a lot of
creative borrowing on my deck
here.
If you've ever seen
Maslow's hierarchy of needs,
this is like the
hierarchy of computing.
At the lowest level
you have the on prem,
you're running your
own data center world.
Even before PayPal I
started off in this role.
I was doing a startup and I
rented a rack in a data center,
and I went down and I racked
these physical servers.
And then I installed
Oracle on them,
and it felt really, really cool.
I was dealing with
thyis heavy metal.
But it's a lot of
work, actually.
You have to deal with physical
security, network hardware,
physical servers,
them going down,
the internet connectivity,
even if you're just
renting out a data center.
Most of that stuff
isn't differentiated.
If you're differentiating
on how you rack servers--
maybe you are.
I mean, if you're building
some crazy infrastructure that
is a place to differentiate.
I mean, I think that's really
where the cloud providers
differentiate is how they
operate that layer, or even
Google outside of the cloud.
Google's done a lot of
cool, special things
in building these really
amazing data centers that
let us operate at global scale.
So you can innovate it there
but most companies don't.
So the next layer up is cloud,
and cloud is really just
where you take all the physical
stuff out but you're really
doing the same things.
You have virtual machines.
You have virtual networks.
You deal with
cluster management.
You still deal with OS updates.
Again, how many people do they--
how many people do you feel
that your companies are
differentiating based on how
well you update the operating
systems on your
virtual machines?
Maybe, but I doubt it.
So the next level
up is serverless,
and that's where you get
rid of all this other stuff.
You just focus on
application development.
In an ideal world it would be
just application development
here.
You just write the
code for your app.
In reality, you have to still
monitor the performance.
You're going to run into some
scaling issues eventually.
You need to do some
re-architecture so you
need to keep track of that.
But really, you're just focusing
on developing your software,
your code, your business logic.
That's where I think
90% of companies
differentiate these days.
And then Maslow's
hierarchy of needs.
Once you've met all the needs,
like eating and sleeping
and all those other things,
you have self-actualization.
And so I think if you
do all these things
you can self-actualize
and actually build
great products,
which is hopefully
what we all want to do.
And I think as you go
up the stack obviously
you get more productivity.
The less other
stuff you have to do
the more you focus on
the stuff that matters,
so that's why serverless.
Now we're going to shift into
the other part of the talk.
I kind of mentioned that
there's two talks in one
here, which is what's
new in App Engine.
How many folks are
current App Engine users?
Have you guys tried out
the second gen runtimes?
Anyone?
So this is the big
thing that's new.
We've been releasing
what we've been
calling the second generation
App Engine runtimes since--
if I stand out of the
light can you still see me?
It's really blaring over there.
Yeah?
Good.
So we released what we called
second generation run times.
And I wish I had
all this on a slide,
but I'm just going to talk
through it a little bit.
App Engine of 10 years ago was--
it actually, for those
of you who don't know,
it predated Google Cloud.
Yes, question?
Thumbs up.
It's good.
Yeah, it is good.
It predated Google Cloud.
The reason it's not called
Google Cloud App Engine is
because there was no Google
Cloud when App Engine
[? existed. ?] I think it's one
of the only products in Google
Cloud that is usually referred
to as Google X, Google App
Engine is the common
moniker for it.
Almost everything
else is Cloud--
Cloud Spanner,
Cloud Memorystore,
Cloud Compute Engine.
And it was this
all-in-one product.
Because there was no
rest of the cloud,
you've got everything
all together.
You had data store
for storing your data.
You had MemcacheG which was
a Google proprietary variant
of Memcache.
You had a search API.
You had a Users API for
managing your users.
Is anyone using the Users API?
It's great, but if you were
building an app today--
so for those of
you who don't know,
the Users API--
literally you can
use an API that will
manage your user
data so you don't need to have
a users table in your app.
But you would never
build an app that way
if you're building from scratch.
You would just
have a users table.
There's a ton of libraries
in every language that
help you manage users
and that's how you do it,
but that was what was built.
There were a bunch of other
restrictions because--
and this isn't
widely publicized,
but because it
predated Google Cloud,
Google App Engine was
and still does runs
in the same Borg cluster as
the rest of Google proper.
It's running right
alongside of Search and Ads
and all those
other products that
make the real money for Google.
And so App Engine, as a
result, was super locked down.
You didn't even have
direct network access.
You could not just call
out to a network address,
so you had to use this
API called URL Fetch.
And you'd call
the URL Fetch API,
and then some other
service would go fetch
what you were looking for.
So it was just a very
funky, funky environment.
So what we've done on the
second generation runtime
since we started
releasing last year
is we've basically defunked it.
We took out those
proprietary APIs.
There's no Users API.
You just do the users yourself.
You have direct network access.
And most API client
libraries will work for you.
The first language on the second
generation runtimes was Node.
It's actually been
getting great uptake.
Node was not available in App
Engine standard prior to that,
and now we have all
these languages.
A couple of these
were out before.
A lot of them we just
announced at the conference.
So Google Cloud has seven
languages that we support.
We now have six out of the
seven on the second generation
runtimes.
A couple of these are alpha.
It's really easy.
If you want to get into the
alpha you can just ping me.
We basically let everybody in
even though it's officially
a private alpha.
Maybe you've heard
about Cloud Run.
That was the big serverless
announcement at the conference.
These App Engine second
generation runtimes
are running on the same
infrastructure as Cloud Run.
They're running actually
in Docker containers.
And Cloud Run is, from a
simplified point of view,
it's just removing the App
Engine code building layer
and exposing the
containers directly to you.
So I've got all these now.
These are modern languages.
You should try them out.
And this is a you
heard it here first.
On those second
generation runtimes
we are doubling the
memory that you get.
Right now the smallest instance
class you get 128 megs of RAM.
That hasn't changed in a
while, and what we're seeing
is actually that most apps,
even really simple ones,
don't fit in 128 megs anymore.
So all the second
generation runtimes
are going to get double the RAM.
We'll be shipping
that this quarter.
I'm crossing my
fingers that it's
going to happen in
the next six weeks,
but officially
sometime this quarter.
There'll be no price change.
You'll get double the memory
on second generation runtimes.
So surprise, it's
going to be really fun.
Like I said before, and this
is really, really important,
the second generation runtimes
enable open network access.
Why is that important?
Well, Google Cloud's
got some cool stuff.
There is cloud storage
for storing your blobs.
That wasn't available
in the old App Engine.
It's available in the new one.
There's Cloud Spanner, where
you can have a database that's
on multiple continents.
On the last session,
I demoed an app
that was running on multiple
continents using Spanner.
But without open network
access you couldn't actually
use any of those APIs.
So now with open
network access you
can just use the Google
Cloud client library
and access those
Google APIs directly.
But like I said--
and this is where the
product's a little complicated.
Because App Engine is still
running in that main Google
Borg cluster, it actually
is not on the same network
as the virtual machines
that you might spin up
in Google Cloud proper.
And a lot of the
products in Google Cloud,
like notably Cloud
Memorystore, are
based on the virtual machines.
So besides network access,
the really, really big thing
that we announced
here is VPC Connect.
So Google Cloud has VPCs.
I'm not a networking guy.
Network, to me, is
like magic pixie dust,
but what's cool is
it really is magic.
It works.
So this is a really
cool town in France.
The road to it gets under
water on very high tides.
It's just like a little
jewel box [INAUDIBLE] town.
So this is App Engine
before VPC Connect.
It was just this little island.
Really great if you had
what you want on the island.
But with VPC Connect, we've
got a bridge from the island
to the mainland.
Kind of a cute, little analogy.
But the important
thing here is you can
have your VMs in Google Cloud.
The number one
feature that's been
asked for on the second
generation runtimes
has been a caching service--
Memcache or Redis.
So you can spin up
your Redis instance,
and later on when it's
available a Memcache instance.
It's in a VPC.
You create a VPC
connector in App Engine
and you just address it on
its internal 10.0.-whatever
address, and it works.
And actually, that was--
so far, for the
folks who have been
using the second
generation runtimes,
it's been the number
one requested feature.
It's just having a cache.
And this delivers that.
[MUSIC PLAYING]